and the TV presenter and columnist for
the Sun newspaper says he has emailed
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex to
apologize personally for comments he
made about Megan in a column he wrote In
The Sun newspaper he has put a rather
lengthy statement on Instagram I'm going
to read it to you it starts one of the
strange things I've noticed in recent
times is that whenever an MP or a
well-known person is asked to apologize
for something no matter how heartfelt or
profound that apology may be it is never
enough for the people who called for it
in the first place so I'm going to try
and buck the trend this morning with an
apology for the things I said in a sun
column recently about Meghan Markle I
really am sorry all the way from the
balls of my feet to the follicles on my
head this is me putting my hands up it's
a mayor culpa with bells on Jeremy
Clarkson goes on to say usually I read
what I've written to someone before
filing but I was home alone on that
fateful day and in a hurry okay so when
I'd finished I just pressed send and
then when the column appeared the next
day the landmine exploded it was a slow
Rumble to start with and I ignored it
but then the rumble got louder so I
picked up a copy of the sun to see what
all the fuss was about we've all been
there I guess in that precise moment
when we suddenly realized we've
completely messed up you are sweaty and
cold at the same time and your head
pounds and you feel sick I couldn't
believe what I was reading had I really
said that it was horrible Jeremy
Clarkson goes on to say
I knew what had happened straight away
I'd been thinking of a scene in Game of
Thrones but I'd forgotten to mention
this so it looked like I was actually
calling for revolting violence to rain
down on Megan's head I was very angry
with myself because in all those
controversial days on Top Gear when I
was accused of all sorts of things it
was very rarely sexism we never did
women can't park gags for instance or
suggested that powerful cars were only
for men and I was thrilled when Jody
Kidd and Ella MacArthur set fastest
everlaps in our reasonably priced car
I'm just not sexist and I abort violence
against women and yet I seem to be
advocating just that
the statement says I was mortified and
so was everyone else my phone went mad
very close friends were Furious even my
own daughter took to Instagram to
denounce me the son quickly apologized
and I tried to explain myself but still
they were calls for me to be sacked and
charged with a hate crime more than 60
MPS demanded action be taken ITV who
make Who Wants To Be A Millionaire and
Amazon who make the Farm Show and The
Grand Tour were incandescent
I therefore wrote to everyone who works
with me saying how sorry I was and then
on Christmas morning I emailed Harry and
Megan in California to apologize to them
too I said I was baffled by what they
had been saying on TV but that the
language I used in my column was
disgraceful and that I was profoundly
sorry over the last 30 years I have
written nearly 5 000 newspaper and
magazine columns so it was inevitable
that one day I'd do a Harry Kane and Sky
one of the damn things which is what
happened with a piece about Megan so can
I move on now not sure it's hard to be
interesting and Vigilant at the same
time you never hear peels of laughter
coming from a health and safety seminar
but I promise you this I will try who
knows very soon now I shall be a
grandfather so in future maybe I'll just
write about that
so that is the statement released today
from the TV host Jeremy Clarkson
speaking about the controversial column
he wrote about the Duchess of Sussex
saying that he hated her on a cellular
level it caused outrage and even though
the son apologized Jeremy Clarkson felt
that he had to go a step further and
release this statement and he has also
revealed that he emailed the Deacon
Duchess on Christmas morning
to apologize for the content of that
column can he move on now he asks we'll
see